good morning everybody okay let's try it
again good morning everybody
okay great some energy there thank you
so my name is Marshall des filles and
welcome here to this session from one
release per quarter to thirty times a
day I'm so thrilled that you're here and
you want to take this journey along with
me to see how we can release multiple
times a day so first let me start with a
question to all of you so why 30 why did
you guys come to a session and you
really want to deliver 30 times a day
anybody any idea why I chose to number
because as gigs normally you choose
another number right 42 or something
like that I mean that's who we are
that's resonates more with what we do
the reason I chose 30 and not once every
week or once every two weeks or shave
off a little bit of speed there it has
to do it I want to unlock a new
different type of thinking and it has to
do with the fact that we are ingrained
with the things that we do for so long
that we sometimes forget that there are
other ways to achieve the same goal and
if you want to release 30 times a day
all of a sudden certain things that
you're used to do are not applicable
anymore and that's the reason why thirty
times a day as a goal will help you
rethink the things that you're doing
today to get you towards your final goal
not a question I have for you is
duplicate code do you think that's bad
or good so who thinks that duplicate
code is a bad thing anybody okay I see a
couple of people waving a little bit I
think that means it depends and the
thing is that and this is where I want
to start at is if you're talking about
duplicate code we are often not aware of
the fact we're trading off certain
principles we're trading off two things
we have learned from 101 in computer
science that when you duplicate code
people give you a slip on the wrist
because you shouldn't do it and it's a
bad thing but why is it bad thing
well in the past it was a bad thing
because it was very hard to find all the
duplicates everywhere and then make
changes to those duplicates if there was
a bug or if I needed to change my
business logic so that was the reason we
have been taught that duplicating code
is a bad thing but nowadays look at your
code repository and just do a search on
a certain piece of code you will find
all the clones in there without with it
within milliseconds even so why is it
still that in that respect if I can very
easily apply a change in that code in
different places because the trade of
that I've been making is the fact that
it's hard to change the code over my
whole codebase is that I now create a
central thing which I create a coupling
on now the funny thing is as developers
what is the thing that we're constantly
striving for not to create coupling so
we're trading off duplicate code we
prefer to couple instead of having it
dispersed over our code base now the
thing that I'm trying to convey here is
that you constantly need to ask yourself
why am I doing this what is the trade of
that's in here and why did I learn to do
it in a certain way because only if we
ask ourselves the question how can I do
it differently or why was I doing that
again and do these constraints still
apply that's the moment I can unlock a
second level of thinking and a new
plateau of enlightenment you might say
in which you didn't say oh let me do it
the completely different way and now we
achieving much more than just shaving
off a couple of hours or a couple of
days in a release cycle I mean ask
yourself the question how long does it
take to get a new server these days not
that long anymore right it's just if
you're using the cloud just a couple of
minutes and you have a new server but
the thing is our processes in our
companies are completely ingrained in
the fact that it was hard to get a
server it was a capital expense that we
need to make we need to get approval
from our managers then we needed to fill
out a form what kind of spec we wanted
so the procurement could but I buy a
bunch of them so it would be cheaper
that's the way our organizations have
been organized but nowadays would
instantaneously compute when I need it
those constraints do not apply anymore
and there are different things then to
look at how we can release her software
and test our software how much do I need
to invest to for example get into a new
market in the past we needed a lot of
money to buy servers but by parts of the
data center get all the software written
etc etc but nowadays we see all kinds of
different startups different companies
disrupting old companies because of this
fact because of the fact that they do
not need a lot of capital investment
before they can get started it's just
somebody at the ethic that writes some
cool code get some tweets out and all of
a sudden people pick it up and there you
go yeah I got a business all of a sudden
the only thing you needed to do is swipe
a credit card and pay-as-you-go and it's
interesting to see that the constraints
that we had in the past for starting a
taxi company I needed to buy taxi cars
well overdid it a different way right
everybody has a car just share your ride
and all of a sudden we have a taxi
company that does not own cars anymore
if you look at Airbnb everybody has a
house why don't rent you an house and
all of a sudden I am a hotel chain
without owning any real estate when I'm
creating content and I want to publish
content I let people create their own
content and I own it still because on
Facebook it's a complete different model
which disrupts our markets but this also
for for me at least a point that I say
okay I need to rethink the things that
I've been doing for all those years so
what you see is that over the past
decades organizations have been focused
on what we call operational excellence
when operational excellence is all about
how can we optimize around a set of
resources by the way if you talk about
resources I prefer to talk about people
but managers and people always talk
about resources but I like to make it
more personal though the thing is what
we see is that in our brains we've been
taught from
kindergarten on is that certain things
belong together and the way we are used
to group these things together is what
we call logical cohesive they're
logically grouped together so it's all
the figures that are around go with the
rounds and everything there's a star go
with the Stars well we're learning
kindergarten right that's the way we've
learned to group things and this is
ingrained in our lizard brain which has
to do with our perception of things now
the thing is that if you look at how we
should optimize our organizations and
how we want to address new markets is
that we need to step up the pace instead
of optimizing on these resources because
what is the one thing we do not have
enough of time exactly that is our
problem time is crucial but if this is
the case why are all of our
organizations optimized around their
resources instead of time to market why
does it take like weeks to go from
development to test to acceptance to
production and we have different
incentives on the production side make
stuff stable and do not accept any
changes while developers on your hand
make as much new code as you can and
check it in as fast as you can but we
will keep you there before you can
actually go to production right so we
completely optimize in the wrong way so
we need to move away from resource
optimization to time to market
optimization and there's a very
important part of the organizational
side of things in order to release
faster now what I would like to do is I
would like to do a little social
experiment and I hope you will bear with
me this is one of those sessions that
you participate I did not announce that
because otherwise the room would be
empty I think so I would like to ask
everybody to stand up please for those
that don't it also gives me some
information is very cool which is part
of the social experiment by the way so
what I would like to do is I would like
to create a baseline as a consultant I
do a lot of baselining and then see how
I can optimize things so what I would
like to do is I would like to make as
much noise as we can in this room by
clapping our hands okay so on the count
of three
we will clap our hands that gives me a
kind of an indication what sound level
we can create based on clapping our
hands okay
everybody with me okay on the count of
three so one two three thank you so much
please sit down this is for me a nice
bass line and of course also nice
applause but I'm not doing anything yet
but this gives me an indication okay
where can we go if we would like to
optimize this in the future now if you
look at this change that we trying to
achieve in organisations is optimized
around time to market versus resource
optimization is that's where we meet
develops and develops is then the union
of people and process and technology to
enable continuous delivery of value to
our end-users and it means that we need
to deliver it as fast as possible and
that's what we're trying to achieve so
how would a journey towards multiple
releases look like if you want to become
a DevOps team and let us take a journey
here where we have this company called
music store in corporate which so it
sells vinyl records on the market and
they have an online shop but they need
to compete now in the market and they
face all these kind of issues they have
this issue that they are now running in
their data center and they need to do a
new capital investment on their hardware
it's very hard to make change to the
current application it's a little bit of
a monolith and how do we create new
changes without giving away our weekends
all the time so that we we all know
probably those weekends that we all need
to come in with a whole big team and
then we all start playing cards because
it's one other person it's turn
eventually to do something and then we
go home at the end of the weekend and we
did a new release every release that we
do requires downtime in this situation
we do something that in a 24/7 economy
does not really work anymore it's hard
to compete in their business they need
to sell different products eventually so
they want to become an Amazon or
something like that and they need to
revamp their whole online platform for
that
so welcome music store in corporate you
probably have seen music story
in the past this is just an old MVC
three application I told you it would be
a legacy application and we're moving
towards the new era of releasing
multiple times a day and this music
store is what we're going to move
forward with the current state of
technology and the current way of new
thinking regarding constraints so the
idea is that music store in corporate
will start off with doing things
different they are going to create a
more custom centric approach they're
going to look at what we call value
streams that's the way you deliver the
value to certain parts of the customer
this is by the way where we already need
to look at our application from a
different perspective we need to look at
it from what we call functional cohesion
instead of logical cohesion where you
see that we have all we have something
like you I we have something like
business logic we have something like a
data layer well that's that is logical
cohesive but what we need to do is what
is that we deliver in terms of values so
the whole customer journey you might say
of getting on your website clicking
through a certain set of products doing
the shopping basket and then checking
out that would be a journey which they
then can compose out of different
components they are going to move to the
cloud
because the cloud tipping point by the
way has been there in 2014 right so all
the companies are moving to the cloud
I'm not sure where you guys are at if
you're in a submarine then probably it's
harder but otherwise when you have some
connectivity then the cloud makes a lot
of sense and especially for this type of
a business which is nothing more than an
online retailer so they are going to
change all these things in their
environment and see how they can align
it to me successful now from an
organizational perspective what they
need to do is they need to create flow
so the flow is about how do I deliver
something and move it to production as
fast as possible with getting rid of all
those boundaries that we had and there
is a Theory of Constraints that you can
apply to optimizing how you want to
deliver to production and this is some
of the things that I use a lot when I do
consulting gigs is I come in into a
company and what I do is a value stream
analysis
value stream analysis is how long does
it take to get from A to B what are the
steps in the middle there what is value
add and what is non value add and what
is of course repeat because we're doing
things wrong and that all delivers the
end-to-end value stream now if you
compare a value stream to let's say a
hose we're in which you can push water
the maximum capacity you have is the
size of the hose right and all the stuff
that you can push through it that is the
maximum capacity that the system can
have in terms of the throughput now what
happens when we have a dent in the hose
then we see that we are constrained so
that is a constraint in the flow that we
have and you can have multiple dents but
which dent has the most impact on the
flow that's the biggest dent so what you
need to do is you need to find the real
constraint what does really constraining
your system and then focus on that so I
get asked a lot Marcelle can you come in
and help us with test automation for
example then I come in and I see that
the organizational part is complete mess
the whole way they do well they say they
do scrum but they are just doing
vertical stand-ups of vertical meetings
right that's that's a complete different
thing so they're constrained by many
other things and the only thing that I
could do is I could add a little bit of
value I could shave off let's say two or
three days over to tile entire release
cadence of a quarter now what weight
makes more sense so I go in and I say
well based on my value stream analysis
this is where the problems are I can't
of course make this a little fixed but
it will at the end be marginal of what
we're doing and you do a lot of an
investment there so we need to look at
what is the biggest constraint if we
look at music store in corporate what is
the biggest problem they have where they
start that's the organization so we need
to start there so first we have a lack
of flow that's the first bottleneck and
we need to get rid of that now this is
traditionally how organizations are
organized so you see that we have a dev
team we have a test team we have a QA
team perhaps we have people that do
requirements and then we have an
Operations team
and what happens if one of these cogs
get delayed well then the whole system
is delayed right it's all intertwined so
what we need to do is we need to come up
with a different organizational model
that organizational model is again
around those value streams those
customer journeys that you have and each
journey has a team on its own which is
multidisciplinary meaning that that team
will take care of everything that has to
do with that value stream and they can
deliver that to production anytime they
want so if you've been in the previous
session on events for example you can
see how you can decouple these different
systems and then tie them together as
one complete system using events for
example it's very common even driven
architecture and micro services but it's
building those sigh Dodos time to market
optimized value streams that will then
deliver you see there's no inter
dependency between those teams so every
team can deliver the moment they want
it's just a matter of architecting your
system in such a way that you can make
this happen
and of course this is something you do
in a day right now this dish will take
of course sometimes some architectural
work but this is where you need to start
then the second part is okay now we did
some optimizations there we are now able
to deliver as a value stream now what
can we do if it comes to IT operations
because there are many rules there's a
lot of governance going on how can we
optimize around this and you need to
actually self the question are the old
constraints still there do I need to
really get a ticket to get a machine and
if I talk to a lot of companies where
they say well we move to the cloud we
now have our new ticketing system where
you can request virtual machines that we
will spin up on an audit or the
provisioning system that is there which
is AWS as your where else I mean so they
still apply the old constraint on
something new which more or less gets
rid of all the benefits that you have if
it comes to a cloud platform so remember
you wanted to release 30 times a day so
I do not want to shove tickets
I just want to provision a machine and
then actually make use of that I'm not
going to buy new hardware I'm just going
to
use software divine compute and I get
new compute the moment I check in some
code and push that to my cloud provider
so you move to the public cloud you get
a new I would say model if it comes to
getting capital for your application so
it's capital expense versus operational
expense you only pay for what you use
and it gives us other flexibility to
actually push that to the cloud so it
really and I always say that DevOps and
cloud are a match made in heaven
because develops gets accelerated by the
cloud and cloud gets accelerated by
DevOps these two are really meant to be
together which really helps so what I
could do is I could take my MVC music
store which let me show you here it's
just running on my machine and and this
is at a traditional application I
modified it a little bit so it's now
telling us that welcome NDC instead of
welcome wherever I'm at this time so
hello NDC you see it's a special version
that we want to publish to the cloud now
so what we could do is we could say okay
I understand this cloud thing what I
need to do is I just go to for example
Azure I create an app service door there
embassy Minnesota and let me publish to
that particular location so what I can
do is go here click publish then I want
to create a new publishing profile so
let's see I'm going to create an app
server select an existing one create a
profile for that now it's searching for
the resources it finds my web app that I
created it's nothing special about the
thing and I click publish and now what
happens is it will package up my
application it will go out to the cloud
and it will push to that particular
location and now I'm in the cloud that's
how easy it is to actually get something
in the cloud I do not have to do any
fancy things no scripting
all kinds of goofy stuff to get this
going it's just very very easy to
publish something to the cloud it's as
simple as this and just I didn't spend
enough money to get the performance here
so but you just pay more and you get
better performance I mean that's the
great thing if you write crappy code
it's scales also very crappy in the
cloud I mean it's yeah the scaling model
goes with the quality of the code that
you really create um but you might say
what did you do here dude seriously
we're here at MDC we are a Developers
Conference and you are doing right click
publish you should be banned from stage
right away because friends don't let
friends right click deploy right I mean
Damien will be in the next session after
me and he tossed this sticker you can
get up even for for your laptop if you
want but you do not do right click
publish because that's like creating a
new bottleneck and creating all kinds of
problems we want to centralize that of
course create a built-in other stuff so
our next bottleneck in this whole thing
is yes I can go to the cloud and I can
push it to the cloud very easily but
what I need to do it's now still manual
I need to get the manual part out of
here and just make sure that code that
gets committed will just be pushed to
the cloud so what I need to do is I need
to do the ICD create cloud deployments
that way and that is also not hard to do
if you would ask me to do this five
years ago I need to go out and script a
lot of stuff and do a lot of moves you
might say but if you look at creating a
bill it's just I would say almost too
easy to be true right so if I go to
build and I'm using Azure Devils by the
way but if I go here and say I would
like to create a new bill pipeline the
only thing I need to do is say well I'm
still a classic guy so it will use the
classic editor at the moment what is my
git repo that's this one over here I'm
going to do a build which is nothing
more than
asp.net web application since I'm on
stage what you normally then do is say
well the tests just remove those you see
what I'm doing here I'm really doing
best practices here and now I say saving
cue and there I have my built and it's
now running on a hosted agent which is
in the cloud I could also make a very
simple adjustment here and say well use
instead of this my local build edging
that I'm running here which is I think
it was the demo pool that I have and if
I save and queued that one it will
probably be faster done because that is
my agent running here okay so it falls
well there you see the job is coming in
and it's now running on this machine you
can use the hosted versions of these
agents they are visual studio versions
2017 2019 you can run on Linux you can
run on some butoh images you can run on
a Mac if you want it's all there and
this is as easy as it gets to create a
build now creating a release is also
very easy these days so if I create a
new release pipeline what I can do is I
can say well I would like to do an app
service deployment which is the type of
application that I'm using I'm applying
this say that this I always go straight
to production right so this is
production I will do one job and a task
I need to select my answer subscription
which is the subscription that I've been
using for the publishing from my desktop
as well
other than just waiting for the thing to
load it's pretty fast to do then I have
a web app on Windows and I can select
the web application which is then NBC
Minnesota and now everything is set up
here so I do not have to do anything
else the only thing that I need to now
manage is where's the artifact coming
from now the artifact will be coming
from the build that I have and the build
that I have is just the one that I just
created okay so there was the asp net
see our latest version and i will call
the location where i drop this stuff to
drop location I add this I save this if
all is well I already have a built now
by now so I can create a release it will
then figure out that built number two
was the one that is now available for me
I create this and now I can follow along
what it's doing and it will use also a
host the pool of agents that is now
pushing this to the cloud for me this is
the way I can now very easily you know
move this stuff in a complete CI CD
fashion the only thing I can change to
my release pipeline by the way is go
back one when I edit this one release
pipelines releases this is the new one
I'm going to edit it what I can do is
say here that the deployment trigger is
continuously so every time a new build
is there it will push it to the cloud
and I can do the same for the build so
if I look for the build here and this is
my standard see I just created if I go
edit here I can set a trigger and that
will be a continuous integration so
every time I commit to the get repo I
will get a build out of the box
okay and that's also very easy to just
set up so that's the way we just build
pipelines and this is the way we can get
rid of all of this trouble and this will
not cost you like a consultant for a
month or so to get this up and running
this is just following a video on
YouTube and you are off doing this okay
it's not complex anymore you do not have
to have a lot of complex software
so where are we we now have value
streams in teams every team is now able
to push to the cloud very easily so we
can move much much faster than we did in
the past so what will be next and before
we go to the next stage in optimizing
this I would like to ask you again to
stand up for me please because I need to
take a second measurement and the second
measurement is all about can we make
more noise than we did in the in the in
the previous ask that I did okay so on
the count of three we're going to make
more noise okay so one two three thank
you so much now go back one question do
the old constraints still apply I just
asked you to make more noise I did not
ask you to clap your hands so please sit
down because this is the thing that I
wanted to show you is that I can very
easily program your mind to do exactly
the same thing over and over and over
again that's our little brain that's the
way we operated I programmed you to clap
your hands to make noise it's as simple
as that and now translate that into your
work field what you do every day you
come into the office do you ask yourself
do the old constraints still apply do I
really need to scan my badge at this
time do I I know it can be tiresome to
always ask those questions with
everything you do but if you're trying
to achieve different things and
different goals do the old constraints
still apply be very careful about that
and always ask yourself that question
because things change a lot of stuff
that we've done for the past decades it
just does not apply anymore
and we need to come up with new things
so who knows for example where we came
up with the notion of different
environments we who has a death attest
that accept us in a production
environment probably everybody and where
does it come from does anybody ask that
question anymore because no those are
just the stages that we need to go
through but why well the reason why is
in the past it took like
a long time to get a different
environment we needed to buy servers
when you had people running around
patching the cables we need to have
different configurations it was very
expensive to couple it with existing
systems so that was the reason we came
up with the notion of environments in
this environment it was then time shared
with other teams and we can then use and
live that stuff for a while and then
people could do their testing and then
we could go to the next stage but now I
have this team that wants to deliver
value to the market as fast as possible
what will happen if I would have
environments that would be time shared
between all those teams that would be a
big bottleneck again in my completely
continuous delivering strategy there so
I need to come up with different things
so environments are okayish if it comes
to the different stages of confidence
that we would like to go to but there
are nothing more than a quality gate
where we want to go to the whole notion
of needing an environment in terms of
machines new environment in terms of
other setups in terms of security why
not work with security from day one in
such a way that you know that will work
in production and this is where for
example container technology can help
you a lot in just building something
that you can push through the different
stages of I would say confidence and
then push that to production so the next
bottleneck for a music store
incorporated is the testing they have a
lot of manual tests and all those manual
tests still take days to complete so
what is the next logical step that they
will do to get rid of this bottleneck
anyone automation because that's what
we've learned right we have learned to
do automation as the problem-solving
theory behind doing all these tests but
why not do it differently why can't we
separate so so first of all one of the
things that we can do is we can say well
we can create automation but those
automations are hard to maintain they're
very brittle to build they break all the
time when we make changes they often
very flaky I mean I've used many many
different frameworks and they're all
flaky as hell you just run your unit
tests or your UI tests and it
perfectly and then two seconds later it
doesn't run and we try it again and it
runs again and how confident am i oh you
want to get rid of that so I'm not
saying that we need to get rid of test
automation at all but I do say that we
need to be very careful to do the click
and world I would call analyst Oh manual
goes to automate it and that's the way
we solve the problem there are different
ways of solving the problem and what we
could do is we can then say well let's
first think about a release a release is
we install software on a machine and
that exposes new features to the outside
world right now those are two separate
concerns that we have we have the
installation of bits and we have the
exposure of features so why do we still
do this in one step why don't we
separate those out build our suffering
in such a way that the moment we deploy
it it does exactly the same as it did in
the previous release and now we move it
to production and still stuff is working
as expected and we have this technique
called a feature toggle we toggle the
feature on and now we are exposing the
release this would mean that I can
deploy like multiple times a day
without anybody being impacted because
it's constantly the exact same code base
that goes to production with give and
take a couple of feature toggles that I
can turn on and off and it gives me all
kinds of new capabilities and one of
them is what we call testing in
production now probably most of you are
testing in production and don't know it
but the idea is that we now have a
formal way of doing this and the formal
way is that you build your features you
check them into version control they get
pushed to production and they're behind
feature toggles and you can then do a/b
testing you can do dark lounges canary
releases all those kind of goofy stuff
that we will go into in a couple of
minutes but this is like a prerequisite
that you need to get in place so start
using feature toggles and those feature
toggles are not that hard
who of you has ever programmed an if
statement those that do not raise their
hands I do not believe you or your
manager okay
because a feature toggle is nothing more
than an if-statement it's just an
if-statement around some kind of a
framework kind of thing where you can
then choose when do I show the feature
is that just a toggle and I show it to
everybody it's a toggle and I show it to
a cohort of users that I select it very
nicely but what you could do is for
example say well we have this notion of
normal people and we have gold members
and gold members get to see the new
features we don't tell them that they're
the beta testers but you just give them
the gold card right they're happy to do
it
you can do the same I mean Microsoft is
doing is they call those people that
test their stuff is MVPs right and
they're not they're not a minimal Viable
Product their most valuable professional
by the way that's very important to know
who's you it's a windows insider a
couple of you right well you are they're
testers right they're testing in
production and you're their cohort of
users that they selected so that's the
way this trick works and everybody uses
that I'm not sure who's using whatsapp
here what's up anybody a couple of you
so whatsapp had all of a sudden this
feature with the blue checkmarks anybody
remember those or still use them so
there was a whole thing going on on the
internet I got blue checkmarks and oh I
don't have blue checkmarks how's that
and I want two blue checkmarks and what
happened there is that they were
gradually selecting cohorts of users
when they wanted to show the new feature
and see how the things were handled by
their system does it implement all of a
sudden an overload on my systems is my
system still stable when I try to
release this feature so this is the
reason that feature toggles make a lot
of sense if you're trying to do a 24/7
operation and want to publish new
features all the time but be in control
of what's actually going on there and
the one and only thing that is really
amazing about this is you can hand the
feature toggle to your business because
the business is now in charge of when to
reveal the feature instead of you
getting to spend your weekend in the
data center installing the software so
feature toggles are really a great thing
to do now beware about feature toggles
because they need to be maintained
feature toggles in your code that lived
there for a long period of time the
I'm a technical debt so if you look at
feature toggles then you have different
types of feature toggles for example
release toggles those are the ones that
I was just talking about those are the
ones that you need to get rid of as soon
as possible as soon as something is
always on that means from that point on
you want to remove the future toggle
because otherwise your code will not be
exercised with any unit tests as well
right so if somebody would ever do
something wrong with that if statement
then you have problems in production now
you have operation toggles those are
more this the fail-safes for operation
when they have troubles if it comes to
performance for example they can turn
off something you get degraded
performance of the system of the graded
capabilities but your system still stays
up and running then you have
experimental toggles those are more on
the right-hand side so you see that they
are changed with every request perhaps
you have permission toggles and those
will stay there forever because probably
you don't want to make everybody admin
of your system all the time right and
those are also feature toggles you just
give people a user or they are admin and
that's a very simple way of doing
feature toggling in there so where are
we we are using now the value streams we
doing fully automated deployments we
have reduced our time to market it into
even so what's next here in the bottom
end well the next bottleneck is our
strategy if it comes to branching
because we are still using an all
technique called for example get flow
and if we're using get flow we creating
branches for the devs the deaths then
create feature branches where they
create new features then when that's
done they move it back to the
development branch then gradually say ok
now we're going to release then we
create a release branch then we get
create some hot fixes and that's
actually then move to master which is
then released to production and this is
a very standard way of delivering
software and I think that get flow still
is very very helpful for companies that
deliver libraries that deliver you might
say on-premise installations because
that makes sense that you want to harden
stuff before you move it to production
but if you're running a 24/7 operations
like music store in corporate then you
might want to choose and say no I was
always want to work based on master and
for this we have github flow what we
just do a feature branch for something
that we're doing we guards the branch on
top of that and nobody can just commit
stuff through there we need to create
what we call a pull request that pull
request is then elaborated on with your
team see if you've done the right stuff
fix some comments you might get from
your colleague and that's the moment
that you even might run at build and a
test release on that on that to the
feature branch that you have and if
that's all ok that's the moment you
could merge to master and that's the
moment it's released into production now
the question you might ask yourself in
the in the meanwhile is ok more so great
that we can now live and move this stuff
to production right away but what about
compliancy I need to be compliant with
iso whatever i need be complied with
COBIT whatever i need to be Sox
compliant I need to be well compliant
with everything that people come up with
right so how can we make this work well
one of the things that you need to note
is when optimizing all of this stuff you
constantly need to ask yourself does the
old constraint still apply so if I go
into a company where they come Marcel we
want to do this stuff but we have this
compliance framework that you need it
here to say ok I can live with that
but I want to have a conversation first
what is the goal that we're trying to
achieve with debt compliance what are
the actual goals that we need to achieve
and if I go and look at COBIT Sox and
all those different compliance
frameworks for software development and
releasing of software it comes down to
more or less two principles I need to
have traceability end-to-end who came up
with the idea who implemented that
feature and how did it get into
production in who approved that I need
to have at least and that's the second
thing
a four-eyes principle in there that I
cannot think of something build it and
put it in production because then I
would be the single point of failure of
doing that and I could then inject stuff
that shouldn't be there so if you have
software that needs to be more
restricted in terms of it might be
medical devices about me a nuclear power
plant or that kind of stuff by the way
you'll be amazed what runs on an power
plant but I won't go there
the thing is that you might add
additional ice to the principle so it's
for ice eight ice principle whatever
just more persons involved in approving
your stuff and what we can do is we can
very easily achieve this goal with the
first four eyes that I want to have on
my source code that makes a change so
what I could do for example I could go
here to my repositories and to my
branches and what I could do is I can
say well on the master branch for
example I want to set a branch policy
and this branch policy now brings me to
the fact that I protect this branch I
need at least a number of reviewers and
by the way do not check this one because
then I'm not compliant anymore because
that now allows somebody that submitted
the thing for pool requests can also
accept the pool request so you do not
want that right you want to have a
switch in there I can then say ok I also
wanted to have linked work items which
is at your board story you can also link
JIRA items to that when you say well
this was the story on which it was
created so you know the business owner
that requested the feature and I can
also say I want to merge it based on
Fast ForWord scores this is where your
development team can complete go say
this is the way we want to do merges you
can enforce that even and you can add
build validation to that so that the
built must succeed in order for us to
accept the review for example ok so
that's a very easy way of creating a
branch policy and that will force me to
always create a pull request before I
can release to production so where are
we
we just created a better branching
strategy making it even faster to go
into production we cannot release pretty
fast but what is the next problem that
we will encounter well every time I
deploy I have downtime so can't we do
that better well yes we can for this
what we can do is we can use what we
call Bluegreen deployments Bluegreen
deployments are pretty easy to
understand the only thing you need is
something like a load balancer between
two sets of servers and for this what we
do is we say well traffic comes in from
the top then we install suffer on a new
node all the traffic is still going to
the to the old installation once I'm
done with the installation and then
starting to move a little bit of the
traffic to the new node and then see if
the software holds this is when the
feature toggles are still off because I
want to see if it still works correctly
and if I get some confidence there
that's the moment I flip the toggle then
I still look at if it's stable or not
and if it's stable then we can go
forward and then gradually we move it up
to you finally 100% after that it's
rinse and repeat we just install the
software on the other node and then we
go and move it traffic there and that's
a way we can very easily move between
servers and get zero downtime deployment
now one very important thing here is
this works great but it only worked
great for software that is stateless
meaning that if you are having a
shopping basket for example and you keep
that in memory the moment you switch
between those of course that data will
be gone okay so be careful about that
now the way we can do that in as your
web apps is very easy what I can do here
is I can go to my web application over
here I can then say okay let's go to let
me look here or you can search right so
I won't have slots deployment slots and
what is a deployment slot a deployment
slot is nothing more than creating more
or less a copy of your already running
servers so now what I can do is I can
say okay can you please create an
additional slot for me I just give it a
name which can be blue or green
whatever I can either clone the settings
or not and the moment I do this then I
get a deployment slot where I can deploy
my new software to and then the other
feature that's in there you see it
already here the traffic is now 100% if
I have multiple deployments loss I can
say can you please distribute the
traffic like 10 to 90 or 80 to 20 and I
can just give in arbitrary numbers there
and what they are doing is they're doing
a DNS round-robin load balancing for me
so any one out of 10 for 10 percent will
get the other node now what happens is
when they get to the other node they get
a sticky session cookie so every time a
request comes in they know that it needs
to go to that node and that's the way
I'm moving traffic and gradually to the
other node there now this is all nice
and handy but I want to do that in my
automated pipeline right so I can create
these deployments loss and do the
deployment there but for that what I
need to do is then go here to my
pipelines go here to my release pipeline
and here you see my new one that I just
created with production on there I could
do and edit over here I could then say
well the job here you can see that I can
deploy to deploy to a slot and then I
can define the slot that I would like to
deploy to now what I can do in good
release pipeline say well just create
one first so I add normally one
statement create a deployment slot
that's when I start the deployment and
then I create multiple stages with
moving the traffic to there and I will
show you that later in the final demo
that I have where I have this all added
so now we do blue/green deployments as
another way of getting faster
deployments 24/7 up but there's still
this one thing and this is avoided I
think in every conference talk the
database because this is the hard part
right what if I make a schema change and
what I would like to do is I would like
to give you what I would say a playbook
which you can use which you need to
adjust for your specific schema change
but you can always run
this particular playbook to get things
done so what is the playbook
well the first thing that you need to do
and this is also something that you're
not used to you're starting to create
software binaries that are multi-schema
compatible meaning you understand the
old schema and you understand the new
schema ok whatever the change might be
and once you have that then you deploy
that binary to production that means
that now in production I can handle both
schemas all the time ok the next step
that we need to do is then I'm going to
update so I pushed it to production to
support the schema and then the next
step is I'm going to update the tables
in the table structure in such a way
that the new code can go to the new
schema there are a couple of caveats
that you need to take in account here
and be very careful about that when you
using a sequel server for example and
you want to make let's say an additional
column in a table please do not always
adhere to the naming conventions that
for example they need to be in the
middle because they are on alphabetical
order because if you would do an
in-between insert of a column that would
mean that all the pages of the data need
to be rearranged and changed so that
change would invoke like a complete
database problem you would get your
database back in a couple of minutes
depending on the number of data that you
are mutating but there's a very heavy
operation instead of that always append
a new column to the end and make it a
nullable column because when I execute
that DDL statement that means that it's
a no op for the database it is just
lightning-fast and I've done this on
tables with millions of rows it's just
instantaneously
now what if I need to have a column that
has a value well then the second step is
you start adding the default value to it
and that's the way you get them to
column with a default value okay so
that's the way you need to take those
steps now the second thing that you need
to be aware of is ok now I change the
schema how am I going to move the data
around because I have data in the old
schema format and now I need to have it
in a new schema format there are
multiple ways of approaching that and
depends on your setup but what you can
do is say well every time my code is run
I will do an update on both of the
schemas making the data replicate
through the new scheme and and let it
sit there for a while what you also
could do is do a batch job in the
background and start moving the data for
you now the letter is also important to
you be careful about because you do not
want to create it there now service
attack on your own database okay which
sometimes happens if people are not
careful so when you move the data it's a
heavy operation make sure did you do it
gradually do not try to do it
instantaneously in terms of a move and
at least test this out multiple times
before you actually do this in
production so finally now I am running
on the new schema the new data is in
there and what I then do is say okay now
I'm going to update the binaries to only
support the new schema I deployed that
to a production and then I clean the old
schema now this is the playbook that you
can run by and this will work for every
schema change that you make but you need
to really carefully engineer this to
make this happen this way
I can do with 24/7 no downtime update of
my databases now this gives me now all
of a sudden fully automated database
updates fully a B sorry
Bluegreen deployments so I can now
really be up 24/7 zero downtime so
what's next because we're not done yet
okay the thing is that I would like to
know how many system is doing remember
that I'm using these feature toggles and
I really want to know what the
performance is of my system so the
moment I deploy something I want to see
if the current state of the system in
the new state of the system are similar
in terms of memory footprint in terms of
CPU cycles that they're using etc etc
okay so that is important to understand
for that what we can do is we can use
all kinds of metric systems okay so we
can inject metrics and those metrics can
come from different types of systems so
we can use a new relic for example we
can use application insights and those
are the things that you get
which are very easy to implement I must
say so let me show you how we can add
telemetry to our system and for this
what I will do is I will right-click on
the Music Store here and you see the tap
application in size if you did not
activate that you can create here a
notion of okay I want to inject
application insights what it will do is
it will then go to I can go here and
then go to configure configure
application insights you get to this
page and here you can then select where
you want to send a telemetry so for
example I it will then look in your
Azure subscription and it can create an
application inside resource for you you
see here that I can select then my
subscriptions that I have I think I have
enough of those and you see that I have
NDC music stores an existing resource at
the moment I will not update it now
because what I would like to show you is
the following so when I run this I have
the telemetry injected by the way the
only thing it will do is will make an
update to your web config and it will
add some assemblies to it so that it can
intercept some of the calls that are
there and it will send an per set of
requests it will send the data to F as
your application inside now when I go
here and I go to application inside I
have the NSE music store over here and I
can go to the live metrics stream and
what you will see is that I will now
have live telemetry this was the local
host instance that I am running and if I
click here on certain items you will see
that the live metrics over here update
okay so you can now see how long it
takes for a request to take place how
long it takes for the penisy calls you
can see the committed memory on my
laptop and you see by the way this is
the other web server that's the one that
is running in Azure that this also gives
me the telemetry data so you see that
the web server there is only using 65 so
a 65 megabit and megabyte
and if I would go here
and do some of these clicks you will see
the same effect so you see here that the
new requests are coming in now what
what's very nice about this is that if I
go to my home page here I can say go to
the application dashboard it will not
generate a dashboard for me or I can see
all the statistics about what's going on
based on usage based on reliability
responsiveness I get all these beautiful
charts and stuff and I can based on this
monitor what my system is doing and so
very easy to add and something that is
very useful especially if you look at
the last step that I would like to do if
it comes to really automating everything
so where are we we're fully automated we
have f ting based on feature toggles we
know which features are used based on
our telemetry that we have and I can now
do multiple releases a week still
because the problem that I'm running
into is the final step is that I still
have manual approvals because this is
because of compliance e for example now
what I can do here is I can say okay
what if for every stage that I go
through I could set up an approval and
that approval can either come from a
person or it can come from telemetry
that I have now this way we can approve
this stuff to go to production only the
moment that we do not have for example
problems in production we have two high
CPU we have too many requests coming in
for example that would be not the ideal
moment to do a release for example and
we can use all the telemetry then just
be the gatekeeper of all of this you can
add multiple of these gates as ingesting
the the telemetry data and based on that
making decisions now the way this works
is that you go into this release phase
where you saw the different stages that
I have and I will show you later in the
final one how that works and what you
can do is then after every step that I'm
taking so for example I do the blue
deployment then I'm moving to let's say
10% traffic that is the moment I can
then add
quality gay there and say okay I only
want to move through 30 or 40 percent if
my CPU uses did not go up if the number
of requests errors that I have didn't
all of a sudden go up and those kind of
things and the moment all these gates
pass that is the moment the software
gets released or gets moved to the next
stage in that deployment pipeline if
there is not one moment that all three
pass then it will be rejected and it
will never go into the next phase and
you can do for example a cleanup where
you say well I'm going to do a reinstall
or roll forward of my changes by the way
the new way of doing things is not to
roll back roll back is for chickens okay
the new way of doing these things is
roll for because you can now deploy so
fast in production the only way to
mitigate problems is to move along and
roll forward that's the moment you can
mitigate the changes so final result of
all of this is then including those
release gates that we have now let me go
and show you how that looks in the final
release pipeline that I have releases
and here you see the deploy to app
services and let me edit this because
then you can see what's going on so here
you see that I have my artifact coming
in from a build the first stage is then
deployed to is staging an environment
well you see here that I create a
staging slot what I did by the way I
used variables so I have an F service
name that does NDC Minnesota which is
the name of the web app that I'm using
you see MVC that's the resource group
that I'm using and you see that I want
to use staging as the name of the slot I
could have used blue green or whatever
that the name that I love to use okay
and in those tasks I am then deploying
to staging I create the staging slot by
nothing more than this command line a Z
web app deployment and then create a
slot give it a name and it will fix it
for me and then the next step is that
I'm going to deploy here to that slot
name that was the variable name that I'm
using so this way I'm then deploying to
that particular location
so let me just for giggles do the
embassy music store over here and then
views and then shared then lay out and
let me make a little change here edit
with five lines I'm gonna commit this
committed to master right away
I mean I'm I mean god mode on stage
right so this is correct you see by the
way to do the build already kicked off
here so it's starting to do the build I
go to the releases here I was looking at
this one over here so after I did the
first deployment I couldn't either say
here I would like to wait a little bit
for a certain next step and that can be
either I want to do a post deployment
approval by a person so I could do
something like freeze Marcel freeze
Marcel and this is my alter ego right
here so I can use two sides of myself
the black side and the white side you
might say and that's the way I can then
approve a change that has been made okay
the other thing that I could do is I can
send the gates over here I can say well
I did deploy to staging well it doesn't
really make sense now but if I would go
for temperature and traffic for example
then I can say okay I would like to add
a quality gate here that can be any as
your function that I invoke that can be
as your monitoring for example that can
be the work items that I have on my
Astra board so for example you could
push this stuff to production all the
time and have this release gate wait on
the final production stage until you're
done with your sprint review where the
product owner moves the stuff to the
done column that's the moment these
different things then get pushed to
production for example would be a nice
way of doing that and you see query as
your monitor this is where application
insights lives so I can then use my
subscription here I can use the resource
group and you see and you will see that
I can then say well I am interested in I
go here oh sorry
research group filter type this one I
want to do an alert rule for example and
these alert rules are coming from
application insights which then can be
anomaly for example in the number of
errors that were there once I didn't
deployment that's the way you can
automate all of these these steps now
here you see 10% traffic the only thing
what I did here is just one command move
10% of the traffic to staging and that
will make the change there so if I would
go and have a look at the current
releases that are running releases you
see now this release is moving really 17
so if I go to the dashboard here and go
to my app services you now see that it's
gradually rolling out on another
deployment slot so if I go to slot over
here I can now see that there are two
stages staging and production you see
90/10 okay that's the way it's moving
the traffic now between those different
notes so that's the way we've moved
music store in corporate to the new era
with the new way of doing things so that
was the final result of the application
now the final result of this session we
please stand up again because I hope you
learned at least that all constraints do
not apply any more and I would like to
ask all of you can you make as much
noise as possible on the count of three
one two three thank you so much my name
is Marcel DeFries I'm the CTO of
experience and thank you for attending
my session and I hope you have a
wonderful indc
[Applause]